how'd it feel zwieback has the doctor
it's great because it's a blast for the
fans because they can now if kind of
fills in it reconciles a narrative yeah
what did you think when he appeared on
the screen I had to pause the video and
some vent out there screaming and oh my
goodness woman gasps man this is amazing
and then spent about 10 minutes dancing
around my house absolutely wonderful I
was so thrilled to see Paul McGann
brilliant it's such a surprise it was
very exciting absolutely awesome I was
really excited to see him back McGann
was absolutely marvelous it may be
squeal well it made me scream with
excitement very very good I thought it
was beautifully done give me such a good
actor well I think it's lovely that
Paul's reappearing I did shudder with
Paul for audio and he I think he's an
absolutely wonderful actor who just
shows us what Paul McGann could have
been because he was fantastic he was
brilliant I listened to the audio
adventures that he does and he's just
made it his own so yeah goosebumps all
over the world brilliant he's got so
much energy and enthusiasm and he looks
like this just normal guy but then at
the moment he can go flick and then
suddenly you remember he's 900 years old
he's really scary he's got a great voice
I think for the doctor really kind of
authority he's definitely one of the
secretly terrifying doctors he unites
he's like I read few kiddies from trees
and then he's like
I am terrifying so many of the doctors
is sort of bouncing around and like
there's a lot of excitement and
happiness and he's a bit dark because
he's obviously gone through the time war
and I had to see a lot of his friends
and fellow Time Lords of going a bit
nasty I think he should a flash of his
leading man ability he has a timeless
quality to him he looks just as good as
he did in 1996 it's been talked as and
there about fans one seeing a spin-off
series to the Eighth Doctor what do you
think about that yes the audio is
awesome but that's happened on the
natural television where we can look at
the prettiness having had like a little
like six minutes but if him on TV I like
that harpy and I always thought it was a
shame that he only had one go at it I
wanted to see how he would develop I'd
love to see more of form again you need
give the guy a chance he's had one
episode and that was it and now it's
gets harder we've not seen its full
potential I think we really need to get
hold of him bring him in and turn him
into a theory I definitely would like to
see well you could see he's matured into
the part by doing the Big Finish audio
what do you like to see happen it became
back it's gotta be against the Daleks to
start off with definitely you never had
a proper chance I'd like to see more
like with regard to like the time the
time war what happened in between the TV
movie and the bit that we saw him in
because there's obviously been a huge
amount of character development and a
big change so I'd really like to know
what's happened in the middle and sort
of see some of his adventures maybe with
some of his companions from the Big
Finish adventures a double doctor story
and meet him one of these old ourselves
I just want to see him running around in
a TARDIS you know like a regular series
just fighting around the universe and
doing stuff
the doctor and doctor who of course is
dead if not now then maybe some other
time
you know because that's that's the
beauty of you know we can always come
back there's too much to say about him
he's just too good he's just we need
more we need more McGann
you